the next question is I'm currently doing
my GCSEs and I'm wondering how many
eight stars I'm going to need to be get
going to need to get to be fairly
competitive for a shot at getting a
medicine on so yeah we kind of answered
this one before with gtcys just do your
best but don't try and get as many
tastes as we can but don't obsess over
the number that you need like Simon said
the average number is seven a stars for
medicine applicant but that varies a lot
you may get rubbish GCSEs and then go on
to do really good a-levels you may get
amazing UTS season then you're fine but
it's just another part of the admissions
process you know unless you absolutely
bomb and just you don't get any a style
or a as at all don't worry about it just
do your best
I mean a lot of medicine is comes down
to work experience as well yeah I'm
getting experience in variety medical
environments because I realized after
doing when to use that a lot of the
interviews to do and can you cope with
the course yeah like will you stay the
course literally yeah so yeah whilst
you're doing your GCSEs just try us and
then after that start to focus on
getting the work experience and
preparing for the interview because say
well especially for medicine yet
interview in the work experience those
are the two really really important
parts and then the GCSEs will just build
on top of everything else is like
another piece of information in its
question well taking IB instead of a
levels reduce my chance of getting in no
no um I don't
why would I don't know why people would
think not just because I
I guess it's because in a lot of the
emissions media a lot of people they
talk about offers in terms of a levels
yeah should point out on the Oxford
website um the requirements are listed
in terms of a levels per subject also in
terms of IB and so there's no
discrimination against it or I think if
anything they'd be Michael how you
better yeah I mean if you do a levels if
you do I be if you do Scottish highs
like whatever the equivalent is in your
country or wherever you want whatever
your schools offering you know Oxford
has to accept it I think you know they
can't discriminate against what course
you taken um the only thing that Oxford
isn't very keen on I think this goes for
a lot of other kind of rent bring you
knees is like stuff like feet x and then
beacuse rightfully if you do maybe two
to a levels on a beat tank that won't be
as strong as candidate who has three
eight levels but you know I be what can
be your chances at all
next question I heard that somebody got
invited back for six interviews but
didn't get in the number of interviews
you have here cannot tell you anything
about your chances of whether you're
going to get involved so some people
come and have one interview most people
have at least to some people end up
having six or seven and there really
isn't any logic to that method so I know
if you have an interview with one people
I don't know
we vary some subjects subjects well I
know thoughts being theology have 6 into
6 into yeah a lot you say you shouldn't
read anything into it like if you're
doing joint subjects you might have
interviews on different aspects of the
subject so like you said for philosophy
in theology you might have one purely
for philosophy one purely for theology
one for both of them together one or
something totally like
I don't know something related to the
subject but a bit more abstract it's
just it depends on the course and it
depends on the colleges you're at some
colleges may be like heavily
oversubscribed so they need to kind of
dish out the interviews evenly around
colleges you may end up getting more but
yeah like you said there's it's
unfortunate I suppose if you end up
having six or seven interviews and you
don't get a place but that's just the
way it was yeah sorry the next question
says what do you got to think of non
core subjects such as a level something
they're non core subjects at a level eg
philosophy of religion and ethics I
don't really know you mean by non core
subjects because I don't know how do you
classify a core subject line using the
stereotypical yes and what was he that's
the point of a levels that you do
subjects beyond beyond the core and you
do so much fun interesting yeah you do
yeah exactly you do subject to mind
interesting a levels all have I think
they all roughly have the same merit the
only ones that might not I think general
studies generous yeah general studies
have doesn't I'm going to get has any
merit anywhere um
critical thinking critical thinking I
think is it does this doesn't really
have any merit in itself as an a-level
but it is a really use my level it's
help you for coming into Oxford
um but yet no I think P I'm not hugging
people here dumpy hey yeah like um I was
gonna name somebody but not 1900 the
other people there DP definite yeah I
mean again it depends on what you're
applying for so if you do on a very like
drama art and philosophy I'm not saying
anything about those over to the whole
if you do that and you want to apply for
maths if you're not going to get it
that you need to meet the subject
requirements so again if you check the
website and it says we recommend that
you do philosophy and do it if it says
philosophy doesn't count then you might
have to make up for that somehow but I
don't see why it wouldn't count for any
arts or humanities subjects I think it
go anytime certainly for these Sciences
I can't speak the humanities or some
scientists but they really do care and
like I said before about your ability
yeah
so if you do if you say you're a point
physics like like like I do and you do
maths and physics and further maths
a-level then if you wanted to do another
fourth subject you could do whatever you
want because they're going to ask you an
interview about your ability to do
physics and they're not going to care if
you do drama okay or whatever on the
side because that doesn't it what's the
quote Auster quote the existence of
brought view doesn't have any taste of
chocolate like your ability to do
something else does not affect your
ability to do like yes are you applying
for yeah so that's really I think is a
John Green one okay so last question if
I achieve poor grades at GCSE three days
the recipes that form well at a-level a
star a a or a star a star a do I have a
chance I'll experiment the good personal
statement slash reference slash
interview yeah yeah yeah
like we said before GCSE is just a part
of a part of the information that they
use to kind of assess you your a levels
are going to be the most important if
you've got good a essays good predictive
grade and you achieve those a level
grades which you seem to have done yeah
then that's the most important part
I mean to you as well so yeah don't that
the fact that you've got another movie
what you would consider mediocre GCSEs
put you off from applying because they
may they may like your GCSEs if they are
not so good but then they'll see a
levels and you might have an amazing
interview and yes you're perfect and
take you so don't let that for you be
filled our charts definitely don't
definitely don't not apply just because
you're not the perfect student yeah
because there are so many people here
that did that at GCSE or something with
the opposite actually induce pretty bad
it's a really great Jesus season and
sort of felt that us a little bit yeah I
mean we can't tell you like anyone who
writes in with their grades of a predict
grades you can't say yes you're going to
definitely get an offer because it
depends on the entire picture it depends
on your interview your personal
statement and everything else so the
only thing we can say is just apply it
and give it a go unless unless you know
that you're not going to achieve the
grease that are required for a level
then there's no reason why you shouldn't
apply yeah I mean if you don't apply you
have a 0% chance of getting in so you've
got nothing to lose
thank you for joining me buddy that's
all right thank you having me if you
guys have any more questions and just
write in Simon I'm sure you'd be happy
to answer them or alternatively some PS
College is on Facebook and Twitter so
write to us
right